i feel like too you kind of have had a
lot of um
a big hand in um in bringing
the black keys kind of to like the
forefront of like no no no no i broke
the black keys there's no doubt about it
no one knew who they was they didn't
even do videos i didn't that's what i'm
saying they didn't make videos didn't
even know what it was like to actually
have brett
or what it looked like to spend it
i burnt them out
and now they're one of the biggest raw
groups in the world
so yeah but you know my beef with them
is that they never ever showed the
appreciation to those artists that broke
them which was hip-hop and everything
jones the most devs
those guys didn't even know who they
were they did it just because they
trusted me and then all of a sudden they
blew up and they were like yo
they were gone
their ideals changed
that's how i looked at it pat mccartney
was very disappointing
to me wow and you know tell them i said
so we got to give you your flowers in
the rock world too man you know what i'm
saying shout out to dame dash we gotta
because because i'm a fan of of of of of
of of that uh i appreciate the leg of of
what you did man and what you continue
to work with black rock too that's what
i'm saying you were telling me about
that yeah but those guys went missing
they didn't want to put it out and i
didn't feel like chasing them to put it
up
but it had sean price on it tyler carley
you know where's khalifa [ __ ]
currency
before black and yellow
what's going